時間は過ぎておりますが
ご質問がある方は挙手をお願いいたします
はい 質問があれば聞きたいことだけございますか？はいはい
はい どうぞ  あの ちょうどお話で
人間は朝から晩まで妄想に回されてしまうというのは
それでこの会議に来るのも妄想と一緒に
そして長老の話で妄想の聞いているということになりますと
長老のその法話がですね
我々の妄想でどう役立たないという気がしないでもない
我々の内側には妄想ばかりでなくて
まさか真理の流れ それに触れるものが当然ある
ですから 真理の言葉が妄想を貫いて
我々の内側の真理によって触れるというなら
そうすると妄想は少しは焼かれていくとしたわけですが
歴史上の阿羅漢なし それからブッダたちは深い瞑想の中で自分の心を深く入っていって
そこで見出したものは
我々の本体は実は光の仏の命
我々の本体は神仏であるということを知ったと思います
それはちょうど初めにおっしゃった大乗仏教というものの音楽思想の根幹だと思うのです
そうしますと その阿羅漢たちやブッダたちばかりでなくて
我々もその本体は実は神仏であるということになりますので
我々の命は生と死は我々の外側で肉体どころですけども
その本体としては神仏というか
永遠である つまり始めがなくて終わりがないということは
我々は死のうとして死んでない存在である
我々の命はいわば永遠であるということに至ると思いますが
先ほどのその死なないというのは妄想であるというのは
ある意味適当的な意味なので
その本質的な意味では我々は永遠であるというのは
大乗仏教の中でのその縁の集い
あるいは本日というところの意味合いだと考えるわけですが
それは長老はどういうふうに考えて
いますか？私は私の個人的な私語を聞きたいの
そう 直らないほど邪見やと
修行不可能やということですね
個人的な意見は 説明は欲しくないでしょ
いや それはその音楽性どういうこと？ だから初めから言ったでしょうに
いい加減な邪見やと だからこの何の証拠もひとかけらもなく
自分の感情を語ってるだけですよ
そういう人々は だから例えば阿羅漢たちは我は光であるとどこにも書いてないんですよ
まあ日本ではそんなことを言ってる
かなりの光に光っている
光っている人がいますけど
だから証拠ひとかけらもなく
だから証拠で分析して真理に達しなくちゃいけないんですよ
で 本来なんだらかんだらであるとか
どうやって言うんです
そんなのは とにかく我は死なないというという邪見を言葉変えて変えて
この料理方法を変えて変えて守ろうとしているだけなんです
お釈迦様もですね ジャータで自分の過去の転生を述べますね
うん それはだからあの覚えてなくて
だからそちらが言ってるじゃあたけど
我々の仏教じゃあ違うと思いますよ
私は知ってますからね
何言ってるのかと 何を参照しているのかと
だからこのジャータカであろうか
だから人間は輪廻転生しているんだから
その時その時の起きた出来事はジャータカであって
だから私たちにも過去でどう何をしていたかというとことを正真正銘で発見できれば
それは私個人のジャータカになる
だからそれを知るためには
もういわゆる時空関係でリミットされている
五根にリミットされている智慧をちょこっと破らなくちゃいけないんです
そこはそれなりの修行法はあります
修行も何もしないでベラベラ喋るものはすべて明確に妄想概念なんです
だからなぜかで私はそう思う
私はそう思うってだけの話なんです
だからそういう話では
悟りも解脱も 人の努力も何でもかんでも無になってしまっちゃうんです
真理は無常ということなんですよ
ずっとだんだんとダラダラと言いましたから
最初からあの真理は一切は苦であると
命っていうのは苦でできているんです
苦がなければ生きていられません
なんで呼吸するのかというと
やめちゃうともう耐え難い苦しみなんです
なんでご飯食べるのかというと
ご飯食べなきゃもう耐え難い苦しみで死んでしまうんです
だから苦が命を作って
苦が命を管理して司どって
苦のために生きてるんです
だから苦に生まれて 苦のために生きていて
苦で死んでしまいますよということは
普通のワンサイクルの人生なんです
それでもすごい悔しくなるんだから
そんなはずではない そんなはずではないと生き方で生きてるんだから
ワンサイクルで死んでもまた生まれちゃう
で それからまた生まれちゃうという
これ破るためには智慧を開発しなくちゃいけないんです
当然 私の話はいろんな概念が頭の中である場合は明確には入れませんよ
だからそれも転倒の 2番目でしたからね
転倒にして 3つありますから
転倒の 2番目なんです
頭の中でいろいろ知識があって
そこをその霧を通さなくちゃいけないんですね
だから霧を通しちゃうと明確に見えないんです
それはしょうがないんですよ
それはもう 1発でやめることはできませんだからしょうがないんです
しかし 我々はこの見解はやめた方がいいんです
今おっしゃったこと それで見解転倒なんです
今まで決まってるものはその通り正しいということでね
だからおっしゃったことはよくわかってますし
私もそういうところは知ってるし
よく言ってることもないようにも
でも一つも事実でなく
もう証明もできない だらだらした妄想概念に過ぎないんですよ
まあ残念ですけど 人の批判してはいけないんですけど
ちょっと頑張らないとね
この解脱には達しないんです
解脱に達することは 我はすごい具体的で
どんな大げさなことでもないとと言いたいんですよ
だから我は何といいますか
死につつあると 生きるとは死につつあることやというたった一行だけででも人生設計してみれば
新しい道が見えてくるんです
光に達するそうと思ったら
もう神と一切一緒になるそうと思ったことと同じなんです
それは浄土真宗でも言ってるし
キリスト教でも言ってるし
イスラム教でも言ってるし
62 の宗教あったんだからね
それ全部もう感覚に添えてガチャガチャ喋ってるだけやとお釈迦様教えたんだからね
初めから 今更お釈迦様に蹴っ飛ばされた話をね
もう蘇ってもらおうと思ったっても
まあ無理やと思いますよ
ただ ブッダの元々の話は聞いてないんだから
みんなもう騙されてるだけで
みんな知識ありますから
本当の話聞くとよくわかるんですよ
知識あるんだけど 真理の情報が入ってないだけで
私はやっているのは このブッダの言葉をそのままのりなく教えてあげましょう
そうすると この霧がなくなると思います
で 病気になっている人がいるとします
その人は病気の原因も何も知らない
しかし 病気を治してほしいだけと思っている
病気も何かも知らない
すると誰かが来て あなた納豆を食べなさい
そうすると病気が治ります
言ったら何のことなく納豆食べちゃう
でも病気はそのままで
そうするともう一人あなた
納豆食べたらあかんよと
あんた病気だから今日からほうれん草食べなさいよと
それでほうれん草を食べることになる
もう一人が来て ほうれん草病気治ってないでしょ？あんなのはダメやと
ほうれん草ではなくてブロッコリー食べてみなさい
それでブロッコリー食べて
また病気が治ってない
それで他の人が来て ブロッコリーとか野菜とか毒が入ってるんだからね
あんた魚食べなさいと
魚を食べても病気が治らない
そうしてまた人が魚やめなさいと
野菜にしなさいと 野菜もいろいろ入ってますから
納豆食べなさいと それでまた納豆食べる羽目になる
どこどこまでやるのかと
そんなことは だからじゃなくて
私はなぜ病気なの？これはどういう病気なの？どんな原因で病気になったのか
あ こういう原因だ じゃあこの原因を取り除こうというと病気が治るんです
それがブッダの道なんですよ
だから人間が苦しいんだとみんななんとか知ってます
それで じゃあ神に祈れば幸福になる
パーリの真理を唱えれば幸福になる
護摩供をやったら幸福になるとかね
音楽歌ったらどこまでやるんでしょうね
ずっとやってきたでしょうに
だからお釈迦様はそんなのは人間に考えられる邪見は六十二だよと
今実際現実の世界で六十二はないんです
あるのはこの全知全能の神を信仰する人々と
我はブッダであるという思っている
とんでもない大馬鹿者の教えと
それのパクリですよ だって神の考え方パクリてるだけで
それから大丈夫 僕は伝統的だから悪口言えませんだけど
伝統的にこの絶対ブッダではなくて
ブッダを蹴っ飛ばしちゃって
絶対的神にブッダという名義変更したんです
如来という大乗仏教の如来というのはただの名義変更なんです
本物は神様のものものなんです
阿弥陀さんとか何たらとか
だからそんなのは今更言ったっても
2500年前でね いい加減にしろよと
人間にもう科学もはるかに優れてるものを教えてるんだから
もう智慧も知識ももう徹底的に優れてるものを教えてるんだから
我々ただ追い付かないだけ
でも皆さんはすごい知識人でしょうし
元気でしょうし ちょっとしてみた
聞いてみれば なんのことなく
もうもう超スピードでブッダに仕えますよ
だからいろんなこれからも宗教現れるでしょう
世の中で 日本でもどんな宗教現れたって
みんなワンパターンで同じことを言ってるんですね
ということは誰も発見しないんです
これ 発見不可能です 我はいるという実感しかなくて
どうやってそれ以上真理発見するんですかね
ではなくて 妄想概念ならいくらでもペラペラペラペラ喋れますよ
じゃあもうちょっと喋りすぎなんですけど
あのまあ 仏教から見れば
そういう考え方っていうのは
もう明確な正真正銘の邪見になります
はい  はい はい 全ては無常である
それから生きていることは死につづること
それが最終的には理解するにあたって
解脱へのお道につながるということは
頭では理解できました
私もヴィパッサナーメソッドとかテーラワーダ仏教を始めたばかりで
まだ認識に浅いんですけども
無常に解脱するっていうことが簡単ではない
難しいということも 見れば見るほどよくわかってきました
私が聞きたいことは どうしてこんなに難しいのか
どうして何のためにここへ進む道がですね
厳しいのか そういうことを教えていただきたいでしょうか
なるほど なるほど そういうのはすごいまとまらしい質問ですけど
これ難しいのは 本当は真理はすごいシンプルなんですよ
私がよく言うのは もうどこにでもどこを見てもあるのは真理だよと
難しくないんです 問題は我々のこの知る機能にちょこっとしたダメージが起きてるんですよ
それだけなんです いわゆるこのあることは見えますよ
例えばこのこのスクリーンで
あのなんか漫画とか何かものを走ってるように見せるでしょ
走ってるように見えるんだけど
本当は走ってないんです
あの そのイラストがこちらにあって
あちらにあって あちらにあって
あちらにあってだけなんです
だからそうやってこの見えるのは本当は止まってるものなんです
それで我々認識する瞬間である
と思っちゃうんです この認識する瞬間にそれ変わっていくっていうことはわからないんですね
そのちょっとした我々の弱みが難しくしているんです
別に真理だ 真理だから地球が丸いということは一度も隠れたわけじゃないでしょ
地球が初めから丸かったんですよ
ただ 我々は知らなかっただけで
そういうことで ちょこちょこっと自分の心をちょっと整理整頓するだけのことなんです
難しくした そうですね
はい ああ もうはいはい
前の方  今の質問とちょっと似てるんですけれども
私も  ４年ぐらい前にですね
テーラワーダの会員になりまして
それでなかなか時間が取れなくて
瞑想の講習会とか そういうのにはなかなか参加できないんですけども
長老の本などを読みまして
その指導のもとにですね
自分なりにやっているんですけれども
４年前まではですね すごい大酒飲みだったんですよね
それでお酒を飲むことは良くないというふうに思ってもですね
なかなかその理由を見つけられなくて
で 一生懸命自分なりにですね
瞑想をしてたらですね
いつか突然とですね 何の理由もなくやめれたんですね
で その理由を探しても
なかなかその理由は見つからなかったんですけれども
これが要するに瞑想をやって現れた一つの智慧なのかなというふうに思いまして
それで その後もずっと続けているんですけれども
今日のお話にあったですね
生きることは死につつあるという
この無常のですね 実感が
このような今続けているような瞑想を続けていくと
それもある日ですね 突然とその
なんとなくわかるような気が来るのかなということを信じてやっていけばよろしいのかなという
はいはいはい その通りです
おっしゃる通りです 私は １行書いてあったんですよ
悪いことはなんで なんで書いたっけ？起これなくなる
悪は犯せなくなる  スライドに合わせて
自然に行う善行為  この悪を犯せなくなるという
だからそちらの掟はそういうことなんです
それも全ての悪を一発で言ったら
それがちょっと成り立ちませんだから
別に普通の人にとっては悪いことをやめるということは至難の業なんです
苦しいんですよ 好きでやってるんだから
悪いことと世間に言われたっても
だから何も仏教の信者も何もしない人は嘘つかないでいたっても
こんなのは期待できません
本人にとってはすごい苦しいんです
しかし ちゃんと道に入ったら
あら もうやってないだけの話なんです
だからそういうことなんです
だからなんで私が酒をやめたんだろうと聞いたっても
ただ飲みたくないだけやと
それが本物なんです 本物に自分が直ったということなんです
本物本物で心が綺麗になったということなんです
それは逆戻りしない それでずっとその道で進んでいきます
だから まあ自信と信頼を持って頑張ってください
はい あの後ろのはい  ちょっとお恥ずかしいんですけれども
長老様のお話というか
お釈迦様の教えを聞けてとても嬉しいです
マイクの方を回します
単純なことをお伺いします
お釈迦様の教え それは長老様を通じて
あるいは他の本 僧侶様
大僧正の教えで とても私にはぴたりと来て
頑張りたいと思います
ただ一点だけ まだ私が納得していないことがあって
それは輪廻です その輪廻についてある部分は納得できるし
そうだと思えます でもやっぱりある部分
引っかかる部分もあり
全部を信じてはおりません
こういう人間が これからこちらの釈迦様の弟子としてですね
弟子のまっすぐで 最低に貫かれていただいていても
解脱ができるというその可能性はあるのでしょうか
大丈夫 気にしないでください
納得しないものはあっても大丈夫ですよ
本当のことを言えば 仏教の話は一つも納得できないはずなんです
だって我々はあべこべの世界にいるんだから
一つも納得できないはずなんです
それで話を聞いて あ これ
この程度なら納得するぞと
この程度なら納得するぞというふうに人は成長していくんですよ
だから 一つ二つぐらい
ちょっとわからない それはちょっと納得いかない
できないとあっても 何のこともないんです
そんなのは当たり前 普通
僕は自由な宗教だから
あなた完全にそれを信じなきゃって
それは全然ないんです
そんな信じる 信じられるはずがありません
ないんだと 例えば涅槃
解脱についてわかりませんこと
あのね 君にわかりませんと
それは だから放っておけと
そういうふうに置いておくんです
だから大丈夫です あの
納得いかないものは もう私には納得いかないというところは
ちゃんと正直にしておけば
ちゃんと答えがおのずと出てきます
そのうちで 解脱に何の妨げにもなりません
はい 大丈夫です はい ちょっとマイクロフォン回しますから
えっと あの えっと 人生は虚しいということと
幸福に生き生きと元気で生きるということがちょっと繋がらなくてわからないので
もう少し詳しく説明していただきたいと思います
具体的に言うと 悩みやら落ち込みやら苦悩やら
やりきれない気分やら
悔しい気分とかね そういうものを抱きつつあることは不幸であって
例えば仕事は苦しくても
何のことなくへっちゃらでやると
試験勉強はもうもう本当に苦しいんだけど
まあやらなくちゃあかんだからやっちゃおうというふうに
このいろんなことをね
何のことなく行えると
ならば それは幸福じゃないんですかね
だから人生虚しいっていうのは
人生に価値を入れることと比較して言うんですね
価値がないんだと 価値がないものは回転しているんですね
だから幸福っていうのは
ブッダ 仏教はいうのは
やっぱり悩み苦しみがないことなんですね
悩みがなくても虚しいは虚しいんです
だから最終的に虚しいとわかると
心は解脱に達しますから
それは究極的な幸福というんです
それで解脱っていうのはこの世とは関係ないものだから
この世で生きている間でも
ブッダの道を歩む人は成功者なんです
仏教はもう負けの道じゃないんだから
もう大胆で具体的な期待
期待しかし作りません
だから我々は死なないように
病気にならないように頑張るんじゃなくて
もうちょっと仕事をうまくいけるようにとかね
今ワンルームで住んでますけど
やっぱり 2DK に住んでみたいなとかね
それぐらい具体的な希望で
2DK 住んでるためにはもうちょっといい仕事に行かないととか
それはもう負けませんと
で その程度でこの現実的に達する目的がありますけど
そこに挑戦しながら しかし執着しないという
なんかややこしいところなんです
仕事はバリバリやりますけど
別にクビになったってばいさようならと
まあどうったことはないんだけど
この執着しないで 頼まれた仕事をちゃんとやる
誰にも文句言えないように
自分の仕事は 例えばあなた
これやってくれませんかと頼んだら
その人はお金払ってくれても
払わないでだまされたって
それは気にしない 私がやった仕事はだから完璧にやるぞ
で あなたは信頼できません
先にお金払ってくれとお金払うのがないんだから
私は中途半端な仕事すると
それはないんです 半分お金払ったんだから
仕事を半分中途半端にしてあげちゃうと
これは自分人間としてはまずいと
すごくブッダで 仏教の人っていうのは
やることはとにかく徹底的にしっかりやってやろうという挑戦をするんです
あなた そんなにも生きることに執着しているのかといったら
いえ とんでもないんだ
生きることはどうったことないんだからやっているんだよと
失敗しないでやっているんだよと
そういう道なんですね
仏教は だから質問されたのは
まあ生きることは苦で
悲しくて幸福になるってことで
やっぱり言葉上ではちょっと相反するように感じますけど
例えばこういうことなんですね
私も今 私はいい加減年取ってますけど
年取っていて 体調もそんなに良くはないんです
で そんなのは当たり前やと思うことと
なんで今立てないし 膝が痛くて
本当に何で私は不幸でしょうかと
2 3時間も立っていなくちゃいけないし
何だこの人生はと思うことが不幸なんです
全然それ思ってないんです
で 今もちょっと座ってたんですけど
ここら辺すごい痛くなっていたんですけど
座った瞬間にダダダダッと消えていきますよ
ならこれって摩訶不思議やと
今座っていた 立っていた自分と座ったら肉体は変わるもんで
この早いスピードに だから仏教でもどうったことはないんだと
座っていた時の安らぎはもう立ってもなくなっちゃったんですけど
それで私は病気になる
なんで私は病気になったんでしょうかとか
なんでいい治療方法ないのかとかね
なんで病気になってるのに治療を受ける時間がないのかとかね
なんでこの専門の医者はすごく忙しくて
予約してちゃうと半年後やと言うんでしょうかということが不幸で
あ そうかそうか あいつは半年しかお医者さんが半年待たなくちゃいかんから
じゃあ半年待ってやると
では その前にあんた死んじゃったら
死んじゃったら別にそれで話終わりでしょうね
死んじゃったらよかったとお医者さんに会う約束はそれで叶わなくても大丈夫だという
その気がこそ幸福なんです
だから 私の個人的に喋っていることをちょこちょこと聞いてみれば
幸福って何かとわかりますよ
私は自分の体調の不調とか
あれこれはと ただ冗談で笑ってもらうために言ってるんです
自分でも全然問題と思ってないんです
お腹でも手術してあって
そちらちょこっと入れ物入れてありますけど
そこはなんか最近 2 3週間
3週間前からね もうあんまりにも感じるんですね
横になるとちゃんとむすんでるところとか
なんか痛く感じるんで
これはまずいや もしかすると
もしかすると炎症を起こしたりして
ここら辺ガチャガチャになっちゃうとね
まあ体勝手に壊れるもんだから
これちょっとまずいなとか
で いろいろ さんにの行ったところであるお医者さんがね
じゃああんた その病院じゃなくてしっかりした病院いくつか紹介しますから
まあ行ってみたらいかがでしょうか
私はまあ初めから紹介した人がいますから
その人に話を聞くぞと
で 教会に来るお医者さんがいて
その先生に言ったら あ
そんなのはまあやっぱり感じますよ
私はああそう それで話終わりです
この間 お医者さんに行きますかと
予約入れますって言ったら
あのね 先生 この間そんなもんだとおっしゃったでしょ
あれでもう自分納得いっちゃったんだ
もう気にしないことにしました
だからその気楽さなんですよ
仏教が教えてくれる幸福っていうのは
だから昨日の夜も横になろうと思ったところで
きりっと感じたんですけど
全然燃えちゃう 全然 だから
例えば寒い時にはもう誰にでも寒い
私でも寒い 寒いのは嫌だってことはないんです
なんで寒いでしょうか
寒くなったもんだなぁとか
鼻水も出るなぁとかね
特に私の場合はすごく鼻水が出るわ
目からボロボロと涙が出るんです
寒い寒い時は で 体さんが苦労しているもんだなとかね
それでそれはいいんですけど
私は 涙が出たって もう下に向いて歩くでしょう
涙が全部眼鏡に落ちるんですよ
なんだこれは とかね じゃあ眼鏡に落ちない
だからこれ塩だから 涙っていうのは眼鏡に落ちないように
ちゃんとこうやって拭いたりしてね
それだけで楽しいか苦しいか自分ではわからないんです
しかし 苦しいや嫌だということは全く生まれません
誰がそばにいたならば
何かとんでもない冗談を言いますよ
それについて だから良いことが起きても
悪いことが起きても 私にとっては笑い話以外何もないんです
あの駅でどんな駅で行ったっけ
えーと あ ここら辺の駅ですけど
駅のあのエスカレーターがあって
私はエスカレーターのあるところで待っていたんです
あの電車に乗ろうと森下の方に
それで乳母車に赤ちゃんを乗せてお母さんが来たんです
それでもエスカレーターで改札口まで行きたいんですね
それはそれでいいんです
それでいきなりチョンとドアの真ん真ん中にこれを入れて待ってるんですね
そうするとエスカレーターが降りてきてドアを開けるんですよ
開けたら あら 中にもう一人お母さんが同じ乳母車で子供を乗せているんです
こちらが入れません あちらは出ることはできません
それ どけばいいでしょうね
どけませんね そうですか
中に入ったお母さんがやっと何となくして
自分の子供をガチャガチャと持っていって
お辞儀しながら私にこれほど笑うことはないんですね
それで私は思ったのは
なんで乳母車引いてるお母さんたちが運転下手なのか
いつでも見るんでそれが
そこで思い浮かんだんですよ
あの電車に乗る時でもガチャガチャっと入れるんですよ
子供は死んでも構わないって
もっと丁寧に引いてくれないんですよ
そこであの目が見えない人々に
この足の感覚で行くために
何かのギサギサあるでしょうね
そんなものはどうでもいい
それであちらにぶつかるわ
こちらにぶつかるわ もう運転最悪下手
もうそれで子供のことは子供って何にも言わないんですね
それで私は自分でストーリーを作るんです
子供は母親に乳母車に乗せたら
もう命は終わりだと もう気にすることじゃないんだと思う
死んだら同然だから まあいいやと
もう泣くことにしないと
抱っこしたりいろいろすると泣いたりするんですよ
なぜかというと 期待あるんですよ
命守ってくれる 乳母車に入れると
もうもう終わり もうだから乳母車に入れた子供は泣かないんだ
もうなんかあのスカイダイビングするでしょ
一旦飛行機から飛び込んだら
パラシュートは開けれるかないかとわかりませんよ
もしスカイダイビングする人が糸を引いても開けてくれなかったら
泣く必要ないんですもん
その気分でいるんだと
赤ちゃんたちはと ストーリー作ったの
その瞬間で ちょっとこうやって引っ張っただけで
もうちょっと後ろに行かなかったんですよ
場所があるのに まあだからこの世の中ってね
気楽に何をやったっても
なんか冗談で笑う笑いの原因であって
悩みの種じゃないんだと
だから我々にとってはもう何が起ころうがすぐ笑えるんです
あっ 大変だ なんでこんなことってないんです
だからそれが幸福じゃないかなと思いますよ
私たちの人 なんでこんなこと起きたところで大変だとかね
っていうことあるでしょうに
それで精神的に苦しむんですよ
別に大変なことは一つも起きません
この世の中に 変なことならいくらでも
だってみんな論理的に考えないでしょうに
それであの一応駅ドアを合わせて乗ったんだから
こちらの場合はなぜ合わせて乗ったかというと
このエレベーターに乗りたかったんです
で 階段はたくさんありますから
時間はなくなるっていう
それであって早くっていうことで
それでエレベーターに乗ったところで
男で恥ずかしいことをやってるんだと私は思うんです
なぜかというと 日本の駅のエレベーターっていうのは
全部若い娘さん用なんです
老人用じゃないんです
書いてありますけど 車椅子用とかね
みんな今度大体二十代の女の子でサーッと入って
で それで行くんだ 歩かない
階段上がらないんですね
だから今日私乗ったのも 2人がいたんですね
女の子 恥ずかしいな これは
このこの年と一緒にな
一緒と扱ってもらったらね
まあ女でもないし まだ二十歳でもないし
それでエスカレーターに乗って
あんたは恥ずかしくないのかと自分に言うんです
それで何に笑ってるかというと
なんでこの娘さんたちがね
階段で上がらないかと
その年で体使わなきゃダメでしょうに
なんでおじいさん おばあさん
足が不自由な人のためにと用意してるエレベーターにわざわざといって
村までサーっともう それで幡ヶ谷駅で見た時
本当に体の不自由というかではなく
年ですけど 体が弱い二人
おばあちゃまが二人と待っていた
いたんですけど これ娘さんたちが入っちゃったんだから
はい どうぞお先にと だからあなた方は恥ずかしくはないではないかと
私は自分が恥ずかしいんだから
2  3回わざと膝がすごく痛かった時は乗ったんで
その時その経験なんで
やっぱり自分が入るところじゃないんだと
どうしても階段上がれないぐらい膝が痛かった時あったんです
それであのエスカレーターに乗ってみたんですけど
まあ最悪 だからそれが私にとっては面白くてたまらんですよ
人間やってるわとは 例えば電車に乗ってみると
座席がちょこっとでも空いてると
一番先に飛んで座るのはちっちゃな子供たちでしょ
だから逆立ちしたっても
つり革にぶら下がってても
何やっても元気なのに
ちょっと空いてるんだから
サッと行って座ったりするとか
それ見て楽しいんですよ
なんて方 老人でしょうかね
まあだから人間やってるへ理屈なことっていうのはいくらでもありますしね
だから笑えないものは何もないんですよ
だからそれなんで人間発見しないのでしょうかとかね
大変なことが起きた 大変なことが起きたと
もう顔を真っ赤になって汗たらして起きません
大変なことはいいと思います
変なことならもうもう四六時起きますけど
大変なことは起きません
大変なことにはないよ
今度は検査したところで
ちょっと癌だと言われたんだと
別にあんた器用がんになったわけじゃないでしょうに
同じ癌でまあ五 六年もいたでしょうにと
ただ知っただけでしょうに
だからこれから大変じゃないんだよと
癌だと知らない間に本当は大変でしたのに
その時知らなかったでしょうと
だからそこは私にとっては面白くて
もうなかなか悲しいのは相手に言えないんですね
だからもう私の調子がそんなのはもう治りませんよと
ある医者に言われて そんなのは治りませんと言ったら
私はいい医者に出会ってよかったと
この人は医者の割に頭がいいなと思ったんです
本当に真面目に だって医者ってのは嘘ばっかりして患者さんを騙すでしょ
なんのことなく随分乱暴で治りませんね
でもすごく気分がよくなったんです
あ そういえばそうですねと
私 それからその病気は全然訴えようともしないし
自分が病気だとも思わないんです
当たり前 だから面白いんですよ
病気があっても当たり前だとしたら
何のこともない いわゆる病気を治したわけでもないんです
苦しみが消えたわけでもないんですけど
何のこともないという
その不思議さなんですよ
この人生は虚しいなのに幸福の道があるっていうところは
ちょっと喋りすぎ はい
もう一人  あの長老様の本を読みまして
今日初めて参加しまして
大変有意義な話を聞かせていただいてありがとうございます
で あの まあ興味本位の質問で申し訳ないんですけども
あの 私に考えるに 悟りっていうのはですね
もうもしずっと修行して運が良かったら悟れるかもしれない
雲の上の虹みたいな蜃気楼のようなものだと思っている感じがあるんですけども
あのテーラワーダの仏教をですね
修行してらっしゃる僧侶の方々でですね
阿羅漢っていうレベルに達した方っていうのは
現在どれくらいいらっしゃるでしょうか
それをちょっとお聞きしたかったんですけど
それはね あの 誰もわかりません
なぜならば 自分が修行して
本当に本当に成長するから
師匠以外誰にも口を開けません
だから知る方法がないんです
それだけは決して我々は宣伝しません
なれるんだよということは堂々と言うんです
あの人なってるんだから
ほら 見てくださいって
そんな俗世間のだらしない宣伝だけはもうこれ禁止です
偉大なる世界については
もう遊びのおもちゃにはしないんです
で 蜃気楼じゃなくて 解脱の境地こそ本物の世界で
今我々は蜃気楼の世界でいるんです
ですから この我々の仕事は
この幻覚を破るだけのことなんです
それで悟りには達せます
達せられます ご興味で質問されても
そちらでも一旦瞑想を始めて
もうただガタガタなんとかやっている場合は自慢したくなるんです
私はこれぐらいやっている
これぐらいやっているとか
どんどん心は成長過程に入っちゃうと黙ってるんです
誰にも言わないで しかし
アドバイス欲しい時は瞑想を教えてくれる人にだけ
まあこうなってるんだけど
どうなってるんでしょうかとは聞きますけど
そこは本当に興味で みんな知りたいっていうのは気持ちがあるんですけど
どうにもならんですよ
同じ仲間以外は報告しないんです
たとえ私が発表しても
もし私が直々に聞いたならば言わないんです
3人目とか繋がって噂として流れると
そういう話もあるそうと言うんであって
その時は噂だからもう本物かどうかもわからないんです
ただ 私は個人的にはもう何かこういうこういうことで
こういうこういうことではないかと言っちゃうと
ああ そうですね それで終わり話は
もうそれ以上誰にもそれは口を割れないんですね
なんかそういう世界なんです
やっぱりなんかわからない
言う気にはならないんですね
なんか面白いことをなんか一致団結してもらって言わないことが好きであると
そこでそれまた自然なんですよ
言いたいんだけど言わない
それもないんです 言いたいんだけど
やっぱり言ったらまずいんだからやめましょうともないんです
ちょっとそれは預流果や不還果のそれ全部共通ですか
大体ね 大体預流果になる前でも瞑想は結構レベルがありますから
そこに行くとやっぱりじゃあ黙っておこうとになります
見込みがない 能力が足らない場合は
もう言いふらす可能性はないわけじゃないんです
それですぐ まあやっぱりこの人はここで終了ということになるんです
それ法則ですよ だって自我発端だからね
それで引っかかるんです
だから仏教では戒めの中でものすごい厳しく戒めてるセクションなんです
これだけではもう悟りがなくなりますからね
一番悪いことなんです
だから一般の社会はね
仏教に興味ない人々やら
初めて仏教は何ものか知りたい人々やらはやっぱり知りたいんですよ
でもどうにもならんね
逆も同じでしょう 神父さんたちに聞いてみる
あんた本当に知ってますか？神の存在は
知らないのに信じているでしょうに
だからそれじゃなくて
こちらではもうもっとはっきりと結果は出してますよ
ちょっと瞑想してみたっても
それなりの人格は変えさせて見せてるはずなんです
仏道は だからちょっと匂い嗅いだだけでも満腹になるぐらいすごいものだったら
食べてみたらどういうものかと
とりあえず考えてくださいと
仏教の匂い嗅いだだけでも幸せ感じるというすごい世界なんです
ちゃんとやってみれば
確実に解脱には達します
達する人々は まあこれは宣伝はしないんです
はい ではまあ では 本当に皆様遅くなりますので
私はいくらでも大丈夫ですけど
この辺で終了させていただきます
長い時間本当にどうもありがとうございます
では よくこのお経文を
唱えますので 合掌して聞いてください
サッビイティヨイワンジャントゥ サッバローゴイナッセク マーテーバワットワンプラーヨー スキーティガーユコーバヴァー
ババトゥサッバマングララン ラッカントゥサッバデーヴァター
サッバブッダヌバーヴェーナ サッバダンマヌバーヴェーナ サッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナ サラースッティバワントゥティ
アビワダナシーウィッサー ニッチャンワッダーパチャイノー
チャンタラローダンマーワンダンティ アユワンノー スカンバラン
アーユラーローギャ サンプッティ サッガ サンプッティ メーワチャ アトー ニンバーナ サンプッティ イミナーテー サミンジョトゥ
サートゥ サートゥ サートゥ
どうもありがとうございます
あの 終了になりますので